Walker Road in David there's lots of
criticisms about what won't prevent mass
shootings and gun deaths more generally
so what should be done in your opinion
what would you do to prevent mass
shootings and gun deaths so a couple
different things number one mass
shootings and the rest of gun deaths are
sort of two different phenomena right
the plurality the majority of people who
die from at the end of a barrel of a gun
are not involved in a mass shooting
these are individual homicides and
sometimes double homicides the bottom
line is there's no one change that's
going to solve mass shootings nor gun
deaths it just isn't but that doesn't
mean that there aren't lots of changes
that should be made and the the anti gun
control right or the pro-gun right often
likes to say that one change you made it
would only impact 2% of shootings or 5%
of shootings right but all of the
changes that could be made together
would actually have a much more
significant impact so number one mass
shootings are their own type of violence
with its own challenges and solutions
suicides with guns are another gang
violence is another so 100 percent
background checks
absolutely absolutely yes not everyone
is going to get guns legally that's the
argument from the anti gun control right
they say people will just get guns
illegally they won't even have an
opportunity for a background check fine
it won't impact everybody well it will
impact some people there's no good
reason not to have 100% background
checks number two mandatory waiting
period yes it won't stop everyone from
killing themselves or others with guns
if the gunman thinks ahead they'll get
guns ahead of time if they know that
there's a waiting period but not
everybody will you will stop some
shootings with a mandatory waiting
period you will stop some suicides with
the same mandatory waiting period number
three we need a flagging system if
someone buys 33 guns in 13 months
like the recent Las Vegas shooter maybe
there is something that could be
triggered by those purchases but of
course if you oppose some central
database of gun sales you're not going
to
be able to do that what about the war on
drugs right gang deaths the war on drugs
has created this endless cycle where you
have people unnecessarily in prison many
for nonviolent crimes a lot of those
people are leaving kids behind who grow
up much more likely to be impoverished
as a result of having a parent in prison
typically a father in prison they are
way more susceptible to joining gangs
where you see a ton of firearms violence
so all of these things together Pat it's
very easy to say oh David that alone
isn't going to make a major change yeah
we're going to need to make more than
just one change and of course there's
still the stigma when it comes to mental
illness right you know the right wing
often brings up this talking point
because it doesn't you know put their
guns into danger or the way to shift the
conversation but it's important to point
out that that stigma exists and you know
if you're in the low economic bracket it
may be hard for you to seek treatment
and absolution medication for it no
doubt about it so that relates to the
cultural aspect which is that number one
culturally we really culturally we
really need to distinguish mental health
right there are elements of mental
health reform that should be discussed
the right as Pat says likes to make it
all about mental health and zero percent
about guns that's not the case it's also
not all guns that's it's it's silly to
say that mental health is not an issue
and a lot of this relates to cultural
factors and at all levels the idea of
using guns to solve personal or societal
problems that's deeply ingrained in the
United States the idea that if you have
a gun maybe do you use it to solve a
problem that you are having in society
last thing there's a certain group that
talks about SSRIs they say SSRIs are the
cause of these shootings because so many
shooters are on SSRIs SSRIs are a type
of psychiatric medication often used to
treat anxiety depression bipolar
disorder and some other conditions
should we look at SSRIs well maybe but
this is a causation correlation thing
just because a lot of shooters are on
SSRIs or were prescribed them we don't
always know if
one who's prescribed the medication is
actually taking it that doesn't mean
SSRIs cause people to commit gun crimes
what it does tell us is that people who
are in treatment and our prescribed
SSRIs might by virtue of whatever has
moved them to seek treatment be more
likely to perpetrate a gun crime this is
a real causation versus correlation
thing so will we ever be able to satisfy
the right with any of these solutions no
but we need to think about ways to be
able to pass whatever reforms can be
passed probably it's gonna have to
happen without them Pat because even
after Sandy Hook with something like
ninety percent agreement that we should
have a hundred percent background checks
Democrats weren't able to get it done
yeah now in the wake of Las Vegas let's
talk about banning bump stocks which
effectively make semi-automatic guns
autop rate as a fully automatic guns and
the NRA might support some restrictions
on that but they say that it has to come
from the White House and not from
Congress of course that that's an
interesting concession at the very least
it is interesting and I think that they
have realized you know the truth is that
these bump stocks are not nearly as
common as some of the other types of
devices that vans have been floated for
so it's possible that the NRA got
together and they said listen if we
support this it really won't affect that
many people and we might be able to then
promote the fact that hey we do support
some restrictions when they make sense
it's a gun accessory too so I don't
think that whole right to bear arms
thing the second problem an infringement
argument really hands up in that one I
guess although again once you say it's
okay to ban shoulder-mounted RPGs
you're already conceding that the Second
Amendment is not absolute but good luck
talking to a a pro gun right-winger
about that